obviously we face very considerable
new pressures particularly from the the
the new variant and the speed with which
that's been
uh that's been spreading uh we
believe that uh we're gonna have to get
through this tough period now with
as i say as i've said many times very
tough
restrictions with tough tearing uh and
you'll have seen what's been announced
over the last day or so
about that and and much as i regret that
i do think it is necessary
for us to grip this virus now to stop it
running out of control
uh in in january uh because we need to
buy ourselves time to get the vaccine
into as many arms of the elderly and
vulnerable
as we can and that is the that is the
real way in which we will
uh defeat the the virus so it's it's
tough tearing
community testing and and rolling out
the vaccine and we're gonna we're gonna
continue
uh with with with that approach and uh
i i know that uh it's been very very
tough over the last
few weeks and i must tell people it will
continue uh to be difficult
uh not least but basically because of
the
the speed with which the new variant is
is spreading but the vaccine is going
into people's arms
and there really is now i think uh hope
uh the certainty that uh we will have it
uh we will have it defeated as i say uh
by
uh by the spring or that's certainly
what the scientists uh still believe and
they're still
they're still confident of that